let's go next to our caller from the 71
six area code who's calling today from
seven one six
hello David my name is Frank I am from
the Niagara Falls area how are you doing
today good good Frank great to hear from
you great here so I know you touched on
this a few weeks ago and I just wanted
to elaborate on it you touched on the
idea that the Bernie Sanders free public
college tuition plan is a fantastic one
and that there are calls from some to
also look at the cost surrounding
college such as you know certain fees
textbook prices and room room and board
in the area rent in the area I said this
or this is something I said
yeah well you said basically the cost
surrounding college I remember you kind
of touching upon that okay yes yes a new
week it's not only part of what we need
to figure out with college is not just
how to you know the the idea of making
to its public universities and colleges
tuition free but we also need to deal
with the skyrocketing cost as well
that's for sure yes see my my main issue
with the current mainstream conversation
is that I feel like that's off being
ignored because my fear if we are to
completely make public college tuition
free and that is it is that now all of a
sudden these markets will see that while
students have more money and we can
still exploit that by raising textbook
prices and you know making it so I don't
know the water here's why I don't think
that that's the way it would go down
because when you talk about making
public college and university tuition
free
that's only public colleges and
universities and thus if you're gonna
start skyrocketing the cost of textbooks
and all of these other things that's
going to make all of the private
colleges and universities even more
unaffordable relative
to the public ones and I just don't
think I'm rarely a person who says no
the market is going to prevent that from
happening but I just don't think the
market would bear that I don't think
that that's what would happen at all do
you think that the industries that are
for-profit or the elements of the
industry there are for-profit one still
try to figure out how to exploit
loopholes in the system that is always
going to be the case yes absolutely and
that's why the plan has to be designed
thoughtfully and accounting for what the
for-profit companies are going to do
there's no question about that I just
don't think it's going to happen in the
way that you're describing do you think
that hmm see this is the one question
I'd love to talk with Bernie Sanders
about if I were ever to be able to
discuss this with them yeah if there was
a way to set kind of prices either where
they are or make those affordable as
well well then you got nice control if
you're talking about price controls on
private colleges and universities and
that starts to get a bit a little bit
dicey err for a number of different
reasons I think that the idea would be
if you make public colleges and
universities tuition-free it'll put
downward pressure on the private schools
because even if the private school is
better than the public school which is
not always the case by the way if it's
drastically more expensive accounting
for the free college tuition or tuition
paid for through taxes it may force some
of those private schools to reconsider
what they are charging that would be
that would be wonderful and I do think
that would be a wonderful side effect of
all of this yeah and yeah I I just do
have my anxieties that because I'm
always pessimistic about a lot of
industries that you know they don't want
to let go of those margins that they're
currently making they're all about
growth constant growth I see it
everywhere I go with factories and
everywhere I've ever worked it's just
this industry having been just a few
years out of college I know exactly how
they tried to nickel-and-dime you at
every opportunity yes
right any-any plan is going to have some
unforeseen consequences and some
negative consequences but we want to be
thinking about these things more macro
economically John from Matt Frank from
Niagara really appreciate the call hope
to hear from you
again I'm gonna take a quick break if
you're holding don't hang up because I
will be going directly back to the
phones right after this